un tour du voisinage menée au pas de
charge un douglas enders a passé la fin
de semaine a rencontré les citoyens de
sa circonscription
ce député conservateur s'apprête à voter
contre le projet d'accord de sortie de
robes présentées par la chef de son
parti
la première ministre theresa may il
n'aime pas cet accord et honnêtes a
expliqué à ses électeurs pourquoi
theresa may a fait son mieux mais elle
est revenue avec un accord qui ne nous
donne pas le contrôle de notre pays et
c'est ce pourquoi les gens votaient le
parlementaire n'a pas beaucoup de mal à
convaincre le député de ram ford est
très populaire ici et les citoyens de sa
ville ont voté à 70 % pour le rexy lors
du référendum
donc nous sommes roselyne sont
aujourd'hui déçus un bétonneur des
événements les politiciens ne savent pas
ce qu'ils sont dit-elle
et c'est honteux en juin 2016
nous avions rencontré des phrases be le
poissonnier du marché manfred quelques
jours avant le référendum il faisait
activement campagne pour le break 6 2
ans et demi plus tard ils savent on amer
et désabusé et pas ce pourquoi nous
avons voté dit il on a voté pour sortir
d'europe
point final mais les députés sont
tellement occupés à se battre entre eux
que rien n'y fait en deux ans et demi
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous les ponts eh
bien les électeurs ont changé d'avis sur
la question
jusqu'à 54 % des britanniques selon les
sondages désire maintenant rester au
sein de l'union européenne est de plus
en plus d'entre eux que souhaite un
deuxième référendum sur la question
dans ce marché de londres des partisans
du second vote populaire ont organisé un
sondage
informelle ils demandaient aux passants
si à leurs yeux le processus du break 6
bat bien s'il aimerait botter un niveau
va pas bien cet accord déçoit qu'il nous
faut un deuxième référendum dit allen
comme presque tous les répondants
le résultat est sans surprise la région
de londres est fortement aux européennes
à travers d'exercices organisateurs
incitent les citoyens à faire pression
sur leur député pour se faire entendre
lors du premier référendum
personne ne savait ce qu un départ de
l'europe impliqués a dit il alors
qu'aujourd'hui on est au courant des
conséquences économiques et pour nos
enfants mais il y avait deux semaines
encore personne n'aurait parié ne
serait-ce qu'une livre sur la
possibilité d'un nouveau référendum
mais aujourd'hui ce scénario autrefois
improbable est de plus en plus
sérieusement envisagée ici jean françois
bélanger radio-canada londres